ah
y
[Música]
necesitamos confrontar los liberal
cientos de batallas y que en ellas
tenemos sin misericordia ni cuartel
disparando balas mortales pero estas
balas no deben ser de plomo sino de
lógica y hechos
necesitamos más guerras guerras de ideas
hoy méxico está secuestrado por ideas
mediocres fruto de la falta de reflexión
que nos condena a la pobreza inseguridad
bajo crecimiento y mucho más
somos presos de la cultura adelante y
debate incapaces de tener un diálogo
interno y así sin las discusiones que
podrían ser vitales para nuestro futuro
y muchas veces son cosas de la vida
cotidiana las que nos limitan a debatir
como nuestra inhabilidad en poder
distinguir entre argumentos y
sentimientos misma que mostramos con
nuestro lenguaje suave y florido
discutimos teniendo dependiendo miedo
sobre cómo nos expresamos
acuérdense en la mesa de política y
religión no se habla
somos como jarritos de tonalá nos
ofendemos hasta con las más pequeñas
críticas y está prohibido desafiar a las
pirámides jerárquicas porque el que se
atreva a ser franco o cuestionar a sus
padres profesores o patrones se vuelven
el irrespetuoso el preguntón el arma
pleitos
y por qué
acaso todos los que no somos los meros
meros no somos suficientemente buenos
para proponer cambios
las instituciones de nuestro país tienen
tanta curva como nosotros de que
compartamos dicha cultura en las
escuelas se premia la memoria por encima
de la investigación o el análisis y de
los medios de comunicación ni habla
según pedro makhlouf del centro espinoso
iglesias menos del 2% de horas de
programación diaria en televisión
abierta se destinan a programas de
discusión y nunca en horario estelar
y esto por no mencionar a las fuerzas
que violentamente reprimen la opinión
pública desde el estado de censura hasta
el crimen organizado que difunde el
silencio con sus armas de fuego
no se les olvide que jordania y
venezuela países con regímenes
autoritarios están mejor posicionados
que méxico en el índice de libertad de
prensa
y es por eso que está aquí para
hablarles de la enorme necesidad que
tiene méxico de comenzar a argumentar
tenemos que distinguir entre debates y
las usuales competencias de ver quién
puede hacerle más ataques personales al
otro porque tanto en redes sociales como
en el pleno del congreso la unión
estamos acostumbrados a fundamentar
nuestros argumentos y desacreditar los
de otros con insultos y ofensas
cuántas veces no hemos escuchado decir
no voten por ese candidato s s
mandilón
vean esto vean a estos candidatos y
acuérdense que las drogas destruyen
muchachos no las pueda ver muchas
gracias
estás diciendo ser candidato me está
diciendo
en este date por alcaldía de monterrey
barrios llama el pato zambrano
drogadicto se basa en la falacia ad
hominem término para describir el ataque
una persona en lugar del argumento y
zambrano en vez de señalar que está
siendo atacado con dicha falacia
decide casi golpeará a barrios esta es
la actitud que vemos en méxico día a día
hasta con diputados que en lugar de
dialogar cuántas veces no han jugado a
ver quién es el mejor karateca
pensarán que es irónico para mí decirles
que en méxico no debatimos cuando hace
tan sólo tres semanas tuvimos el primero
debate presidencial de la actual
contienda electoral sin embargo por qué
diferencia a otros países no tenemos
debates entre precandidatos o más foros
de diálogo distintos a los que organiza
el ine
porque usamos el formato que usamos ese
que si bien ha mejorado un poco ahora
con moderadores que interpelan y hacen
preguntas confrontan test aún dejan
muchísimo a desear los candidatos no
responden a preguntas tan sencillas como
ésta ugt enrique peña nieto ha gobernado
con honestidad sí o no josé antonio
déjame contestar primero a su primera
parte de la federación
la autoridad no fue la que lo mandó a
vivir atlanta 7 la autoridad
y los candidatos francamente hacen
propuestas como llamaría ridículas no
habla literalmente o si candy claro
mostrar la mano literalmente
literalmente
recordemos muchas manos violarían los
derechos humanos más básicos aún así es
propuesto con tal de crear un circo
mediático que tenemos que hacer es
reforzar la policía por supuesto que sí
y la tenemos que hacer la clave que sea
de tu confianza es decir que cualquier
mamá que me estoy yendo le pueda decir
una hija si tienes miedo ve con la
policía y otros candidatos hacen
propuestas que suenan fantásticas tener
una policía confiable
pero nunca nos explican cómo van a
lograr tal cosa
verán aún cuando tenemos moderadores
mesas de debate y discusiones
civilizadas acaso los argumentos que son
presentados no carecen de lógica y
hechos no perdamos de vista lo que ha
pasado en américa latina' con ese cuento
de las consultas cada dos años
hugo chávez se quedó quince años en el
poder en este ejemplo el candidato y no
a todos los otros elementos que ayudaron
de chávez a reelegirse no nos explica
por qué las consultas de lópez obrador
tendrían el mismo efecto a esto le
llamamos una falsa analogía
y acerca de la amnistía yo tengo repito
no quiero presumir una experiencia
exitosa cuando fui jefe de gobierno
porque reduce la incidencia delictiva
y aquí la lógica le falla andrés manuel
el haber tenido un mandato exitoso en la
ciudad de mexico no demuestra que todas
sus ideas vayan a ser igual de buenas
argumentos es lo que se necesita para
sustentar una propuesta
tanto en redes sociales como en campañas
políticas nos basamos en la retórica la
post verdad aquella que distorsiona
deliberadamente nuestra realidad
basándose en mentiras y apelaciones a
las emociones las fake news no solo las
usa trump según la página verás en el
debate presidencial se dijeron en
promedio cada 10 minutos una falsedad o
imprecisión son las distorsiones
estadísticas las que utilizan los
políticos día a día a fin de promover
sus campañas al costo de que nosotros
los ciudadanos no escuchemos la verdad
y bien porque necesitamos debatir y
debatir bien sin ataques ni falacias
no diría nuestros padres mejor no
discutas
argumentando nos podemos volver más
tolerantes a las ideas de otros es solo
cuando uno está dispuesto a escuchar y
responder que puede preguntarse por qué
los demás piensan tal pero además cuando
estamos abiertos al diálogo nos vemos
forzados a discutir temas que
consideramos tabú y es solo así como
podemos abrir nuestra mente y ampliar
nuestro horizonte
sin embargo sobre cualquier otro
beneficio el debate nos permite imaginar
un futuro mejor se estaciona como un
cliché pero son las ideas las que
construyen ciudades fortalecen
democracias y revolución en realidades
después del tiroteo en una escuela de
parque en florida donde 17 personas
fallecieron el mundo se asombró por la
respuesta de los estudiantes quienes han
organizado grandes marchas y dialogado
en cadena nacional lo que pocos saben es
que un año antes ellos habían
participado en torneos de debate
discutiendo precisamente sobre estas
regulaciones
hoy ellos lideran un pelotón que libró
una batalla una batalla de ideas una
batalla a favor de la paz
y nuestros sueños de un futuro mejor no
tiene por qué están limitados a nuestras
fronteras
porque nunca vemos a méxico tomar y
defender posiciones acerca de la
situación de crisis en siria o el
agotamiento de agua en ciudad el cabo
al discutir podemos evidenciar las
fallas y fortalezas de distintas ideas y
propuestas y no hacemos esto con simples
aseveraciones nos vemos forzados a
justificar nos con lógica y hechos el
famosísimo porque yo lo digo no es
suficiente
johnson mills diría que solo en el
mercado abierto a las ideas cada quien
puede presentar sus pensamientos y el
mejor de ellos derrotará al resto
gracias a sus propios méritos es así
como podemos llegar a la verdad a la
mejor postura a la idea triunfadora
y es esto lo que me lleva a la última
pregunta
estamos destinados a una cultura sin
esta práctica en nuestro país mi
respuesta es un rotundo no podemos y
debemos fomentar el debate
por un lado la sociedad civil ha
comenzado a actuar y lo seguirá siendo
el circuito mexicano de debate no existe
hace diez años hoy está crecido tanto
que muchos mexicanos en diversas
competencias internacionales han
triunfado ganando los primeros lugares
sin embargo esta práctica puede florecer
y brillar mucho más en nuestro país
los medios de comunicación podrían
fomentar los programas de discusión y en
ellos ser totalmente imparciales el
gobierno podría tener un rol crucial en
las preparatorias crear clases de debate
dándole la oportunidad a millones de
mexicanos de tomar posiciones a favor y
en contra de con 15 minutos de
antelación sobre cualquier tema del
mundo
y en el ámbito político podría haber más
diálogo porque es que nunca vemos al
presidente debatir con la oposición
acaso la democracia sólo se debe amar
cada seis años
méxico tiene un acorde historia con este
deporte verbal mientras naciones como
francia lo fomentan desde hace tres
siglos nosotros tuvimos nuestro primer
debate presidencial en 1994 es más hasta
hace un par de décadas los medios de
comunicación no podían imprimir su
propio papel dependían del monopolio
estatal y hoy cuántos candidatos no
intentan invadir los espacios donde
tienen que defender sus ideas y aun
cuando hay debates en palabras de
ricardo salinas pliego las personas
prefieren ver el futuro
mexicanos saquemos nuestros rifles y
bayonetas porque debemos pelear en la
guerra pero no usemos cascos y chalecos
antibalas porque debemos arriesgarnos a
recibir balas mortales
cuando se oyen las trompetas el triunfo
no habrá sido ganado con la victoria
bélica sino con el intercambio
constructivo ideas
tal vez si debatiéramos podríamos
discutir y acordar más en lugar de
disparar tanta pólvora
y a ti te da miedo debatir gracias
[Aplausos]